[Musik]
geburtstagsparty bei familie benz in
kirnberg es gibt grund zum feiern
geburtstagskind rudi wird 65 rentenalter
abschied vom leben als unternehmer und
zeit die nachfolge zu regeln sich lang
simon ja eigentlich doch wo wir
vertraglich zuerst schaffte es mit 23 zu
schwabe
und er wird sie zu je 40 orte der
bildmitte mit 200
die gagen und endspurt das jetzt mal was
sie der chef der wochentag und
[Musik]
zerstörten des baums ist dafür hat
libyens gelebt habe
der älteste verlag der welt 530 jahre
firmengeschichte 530 jahre drucken und
verlegen ein kleinod mit ewig langer
tradition
aber der drucker branche geht es mies
gutenbergs handwerk ist nicht mehr
gefragt das internet hat übernommen
will ein unternehmen wie schwabe unter
diesen bedingungen überleben braucht es
tiefgreifende veränderungen
ausgang offen deshalb wird diese
geschichte über einen der abtritt um
neues zu ermöglichen auch eine
geschichte über die möglichkeit zu
scheitern
das schwer ist die richtige sache immer
wieder den entscheid der bogen wir sie
jetzt bis an die eu
wenn es probleme sie was auch nicht
einfach so von heute auf morgen lösen
wenn wir einfach nur ssx vertrauen haben
zulauf wird jetzt auch ersetzte das hohe
gut und da aber nicht ganz sicher ist
man nicht doch noch hat zwei uhr bis
sage dazu nehmen die grenze zu finden
das ist das schwierigste
die zeit des patrons ist abgelaufen
frische kräfte übernehmen mit den jungen
leuten kommen die neuen ideen mit so der
sogenannten serious frei die frau
stellte skizziert derzeit mit
dreidimensionalen und pizza und da
kostet ja richtig das ist schade für
euphorisch ist und wo der begriff wird
von medien mit hinter den check in
puncto sichergestellt werden dass sie
froh sind die flocken vorstellen also
der neue auftritt
die monster sozusagen da sind kostenlose
vorträge vor dieser runde auf transit
produkte und dienstleistungen vorstellen
was man machen unternehmen zum abschluss
gibt
ein halbes jahr zuvor
am firmensitz in muttenz versammelt sich
ein teil der belegschaft zum workshop
bei schwabe geht alles anders eine
mittlere revolution waren sich an das
alte organigramm hat ausgedient die
hierarchien werden weitgehend aufgelöst
einen chef view libyens einer war wird
es künftig nicht mehr geben
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist einfach wichtig war
ist
ich habe nicht vorstellen
der manager kommt und die firmen spüren
und kenne und wo die firma die richtig
richtig wütend weg frei seine firma marx
auf eine lange tradition zurückblicken
wie einst aber verhält sich alles andere
als konservativ reform aus dem innern
weg mit den chefs die verantwortung auf
viele schultern verteilen sowie sie
schwabe künftig organisieren ein
unkonventioneller weg
die aktienmehrheit hält libyens nicht
mehr die ist an ludwig de heus
übergegangen
auch das kein besonders nahe liegender
schritt ist branchenfremd und hat
bislang keine management-erfahrung die
neue crew soll übernehmen aber abrupt
wird das nicht geschehen
libyens will den prozess noch eine weile
begleiten dass er aus dem workshop ab
schleicht ist deshalb fast schon
sinnbildlich inzwischen schwört der neue
mehrheitsaktionär sein team auf
veränderung ein
wir haben eine schwierige situation wir
sind in einem in einem
veränderungsprozess
man muss die dinge ändern damit sie
bleiben wie sie sind
ich glaube genau dass das ist das was
wir machen werden wir müssen wir müssen
schwabe umbauen damit schwabe schwabe
bleibt und da sind wir dran
der oldie bands ist sieht über 20 jahre
ganzen und guter freund von mir und ich
ganz ganz hoch respekt vor der
lebensleistung und fusion floss im
werdegang und verdammt was als er gleich
stadt und machte den weißen arzt geht
die tracks ludwig teehäuschen und stolz
auch wenn er vor einem großen wechsel
steht vom chefarzt zum verlagschef das
löst im umfeld reaktionen aus ja man die
andere jetzt völlig spielen besonders
gut eigentlich die meiste beendetes
kommen
wir haben als als ärztinnen und ärzte
häufig für mäßige ganze mannschaft viel
und jetzt nach durchs stroh und am
wochende schaffen dass mir ein anderer
euro also das ist heilsames verständnis
der einsatz soll aber gut macht mir
jetzt nicht mehr
[Musik]
so sieht der alltag von ludwig de heus
heute aus er ist chefarzt im spital
zollikerberg endoskopie ist ein
fachgebiet darüber hat er schon seine
habilitation geschrieben
der basler bezeichnet sich selber als
vollblut mediziner arzt sei der schönste
beruf der welt das c im namen stammt
übrigens von seinem großvater theodor
heuss dem ersten bundespräsidenten
deutschlands und begründer der deutschen
fdp trotz der krise sieht es eine
zukunft für die druck und verlagsbranche
ihre aufgabe werde in einer zeit wo fake
news hoch im kurs stehen sogar zehn
trainer mit sieben aber mit seiner
verantwortlich dahinter steht
ich glaube das wird wird gründe wie
informationsleck konfus welt in der
buchhandlung narrenschiff auch sie teilt
der schwabe gruppe herrscht
ausverkaufsstimmung bücher verkaufen
sich nicht mehr so leicht hat libyens
die zeichen der zeit zu spät erkannt
klein hat vielleicht hat man zwei jahre
für ihr noch einen av wäre vielleicht
besser gesehen
man hat vielleicht habe er fehler
gemacht wird nicht mehr macht lena weiss
ich habe mir das mit sport 7 sie am
anfang vor der ganze die gitarre seliges
passiert haben als er erfährt dass man
nicht einfach plötzlich schluss wichtig
ist und bliebt
libyens ist ein optimist umzieht er
chancen den risiken die buchhandlung
musste zwar schließen ob die
räumlichkeiten bieten und platz für die
jüngste errungenschaft der schwabe
gruppe denn nzz libro flop mit den neuen
kollegen aus zürich werden die künftigen
arbeitsplätze verteilt eine wesentlich
erfreulichere aufgabe als die
entlassungen die bis vor kurzem
ausgesprochen hat acht leuten
vornehmlich aus der druckerei oder
gekündigt de lüt entlang das hat sehr
weh dass beschäftige mich sehr und ich
verlange immer verteilt
das ist ja unternehmerische aufgabe
glüht mitbringen damit entwickelte
technik und sie ist eigentlich sehr
lange sehr sehr gut gegangen
jetzt ist entwickle ich schnell dass ich
vielleicht nicht ganz über autos aufgabe
richtig macht im richtigen moment dort
sie mit jetzt sprach sie mit der
reaktion klar ob wahlkampfs ein meteorit
satelliten klar wenn man stört das biz
alibi zartheit ich sie werden natürlich
das rennen um go
nur wäre man hatte nicht mehr letzter
wenn das anders gemacht hat er ab es
werde nicht jetzt meine sie weit mehr
solid und das beschäftigt mich sehr und
das tut weh
mit worker schlecht gesteht mikrometer
sein dass die cholera war sie jetzt und
es ist nicht einfach mit dem motto das
ist ganz klar der minister schaffen
das ist das spiel ja nein ich würde das
nicht sagen es geht des standes es geht
dabei lustig ist es zurückruft steht mit
menschen einfach fröhlich sondern
menschen achten klasse scheint das
problem in den widerstand
[Musik]
zu seinem 65 geburtstag erscheint die
ganze familie sechs enkeltochter nicole
mit ihrem mann sowie sohn roland mit
ehefrau michelle der zusammenhalt ist
eng das spürt man auch ins geschäft sind
alle irgendwie eingebunden
das alte geschäft mit übernahmen dass
sie warum wir die auch happy trolley
schafft ja schon ewig langes messer
erschafft er ist botschafter wie sie
sich geben habe ich heimlich seine
heimrallye beschaffen
doch da sein wenn es wenn sie aber lässt
daher sagt jetzt die angst der familie
echtes nespoli hätte das eigentlich sehr
für klargestellt
ich weiß nicht wer auf 27 grad ist so
von mir ich muss und ich erwarte nur
schnittig worden um als anständiger
mensch wenig was darum gegangen ich habe
vor jahren und es muss sagte die ver und
eine schwierige branche in einem atelier
vor angst denkt sie ist das meer zählt
wenn ihr eigentlich nicht familien und
schmerzhaft wichtiger und was jetzt
klären so habe ich zur übersicht sport
letztere machen wenn die ganz toll und
ich freu mich drauf was kommt wenn jetzt
der kasse aus dem sohn burkhard orthaus
aus dass größe auf dem jetzt ist groß
ist niemals teil vor dem team deutlich
und das ist super cool das ist das los
los los da ruhe die ich heute präsent
und immer weiteres thema und schaut es
kann halt nicht alle aufstellt
und die danken es ist schon komisch
sagte appel
ich habe ohnehin nicht umsteigen
libyens hat sein ganzes leben in
kirnberg verbracht eine kleine gemeinde
im kanton solothurn seine erinnerungen
reichen weit zurück in die kindheit als
die mutter vorübergehend krank war und
er sich für sie verantwortlich fühlte
das einzig war wurde ihm in der
wichtigen die fünfte klasse hat die vom
leere busse mehr sage ich sollte das
gymnasium die mir gut überlegt und story
verstand der wir hier endlich das
minarett attack side und die axa und das
doch nicht der kirche sieht dass sich
die richtig und dann hatte ich finde ich
gar nicht voreilig war das gute gesicht
hat einfach super landschaft geschaffen
geschafft und irgendwann ihre mutter
mira louen und den hof und das kommt
nicht und heim lehre zahlen erhöhte
finden das gar nicht und der neuzeit und
heike der anschluss verpassten sie die
sportlichen nico und dan hay wenn du lkw
stehen wo es ohne die fh sozialen
schicht sie sich die haare kriegt das
nicht gehört weil jeder mit dem länger
gedrängt
das ist vorerst der linie miteinander
gelebt hat erweckt haben oder wenn die
haut
und das ist gut so
[Musik]
schmidt
vom schriftsetzer mitten hinein in die
welt der intellektuellen als besitzer
eines verlags der vorwiegend
wissenschaftliche schriften publiziert
da wird auch einem akademiker auf den
zahn gefühlt
für als patron erste fertigungsschritte
stunden später ja
die 4x dass das hoffen schon dass sie
das mitgelieferte hin zu tode gekommen
präsident
von den massenstarts europa erzeugen ich
weiß es nicht
horst lied heute zum ersten mal in
seiner neuen rolle vor großem publikum
auf sehr geehrte liebe leserinnen und
leser
sehr geehrter autorinnen und autoren und
für ali danke
das heißt sofern nur noch wobei ihm
schwabe die ganz herzlich sie als gäste
begrüßen und nun ludwig heiß bleibt
seinem vorgänger treu auch er verströmt
optimismus krise hin oder her
darüber hinaus etwas druckerschwärze
aufs papier zu bringen wir glauben an
das buch wir glauben daran dass man
gedanken festhalten muss ich danke ihnen
dass sie gekommen sind auf ein die
nächsten 500 30 jahre das schlaffe
verleiht er sich einmal
[Applaus]
bogdan
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er fühle sich in beiden umgebungen wohl
sagt rudi bieren dann publik genauso wie
in der werkstatt und für spaß sei es
sowieso zu haben
hauke heißt diese uralte brauch der hier
zelebriert wird
zum abschluss ihrer ausbildung werden
seit jeher die buchdruck und
schriftsetzer lehrlinge gewissermaßen
getauft bis heute auch wenn sie
inzwischen drucktechnologie oder
mediamatiker
[Applaus]
es ist sieben uhr früh
mitten in den sommerferien großvater
verband hat den händlern etwas zu bieten
heute wird die neue druckmaschine
angeliefert mit der erfindung des
maschinellen buchdrucks hat johannes von
guttenberg seinerzeit eine revolution
ausgelöst mehr als 500 jahre später hat
die digitalisierung die branche in eine
existenzkrise gestürzt
libyens glaubt trotzdem an eine zukunft
auf papier und investiert knapp drei
millionen kostet diese top moderne
druckmaschinen
[Musik]
ja
doch nicht alle user in europa saniert
worte bis 31
ja ja auch das ist eine tradition das
sogenannte rampen fest zum letzten mal
mit libyens in der hauptrolle und war
bis jetzt auch die beste hatte neu wo es
im ganzen fische auch wirklich langsam
machen ja der gefällt die staatlich dass
der patron am grill steht soll weiterhin
gelten auch dass wir zu den neuen
aufgaben des künftigen verlagschefs
gehören
nach gesprächen
[Gelächter]
die bringen ja ja das aber nicht viel
falsch machen